hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well a central theme
that has been running through really the
whole of epictetus is discourses in a
sort of implicit way which he ends up
focusing on in a very explicit way at
certain points for example in chapter 3
of book 3 which which I'm going to focus
on here is sort of a launching point one
of the key ideas is that of practical
reasoning how is it that we carry out
these reasoning processes that have to
do with with questions like well what
should we do what does the good thing
was bad you know what would be
advantageous to me how do I evaluate
goods in relation to each other in fact
to choose between them or you know
engage in some sort of sacrifice of one
for another and you know there's there's
broader questions concerned of this too
like well what really is the good for me
or how should I be structuring my life
or am i a good person or a bad person do
I you know work things out in such a way
that makes sense or are there some
aspects
to my life and my decision-making and my
reasoning processes were after I look at
them I you know I have a reaction of
what the hell is going on there all of
that fits within the scope of practical
reasoning practical reasoning is is the
use of human rationality including for
the Stoics not just our rational faculty
but are also our faculty of choice
because they're two sides of the same
coin
to arrive at judgments the choices and
actions that have to do with values like
the good and the bad that just in the
unjust the ugly and the beautiful the
useful and the harmful what is in
accordance with duty what's out of
accordance with duty all these sorts of
things that we often call moral values
so how do processes of practical
reasoning actually work the Stoics and
epic students in particular have some
fairly clear ideas about this and I put
some of them up on the board and I also
put a diagram here that will be a little
bit helpful so let's let's look at the
diagram first right we have some sort of
process of inference that takes place
when practical reasoning is occurring
and it's going to arrive at some sort of
conclusion right and the conclusion
could be an action you know if things
are as I put up here carrying out you
know the things were working in a very
implicit way I might have what we call a
reaction but there really actually can
actually be unpacked as involving an
entire reasoning process you know for
example somebody attacks me and
threatens me and without even thinking
about it because I've been doing you
know martial arts and I have been you
know practicing forms I suddenly find
myself with with them in a headlock and
I'm you know giving them some business
while I'm doing that well there's a
there's a it's not just a body merely
react
some sort of reasoning process about
what one ought to do what would be good
what would be bad what what things are
vulnerable in the situation what needs
to be protected all those are actually
getting rolled into there and are
winding up in some sort of conclusion
very often when we deliberate about
practical matters we come to some sort
of judgment this is a good thing this is
a better thing here's the right course
of action we may in fact give a whole
bunch of justification for that but that
is sort of unpacking the process of
inference and all the basis on which we
are coming to that
that conclusion through the inference so
you know you notice have a lot of words
here these are the sort of things that
go into practical reasoning it's not
just beliefs and judgments that we
happen to hold in which we bring to the
table so to speak I should have put in
there as well
preconceptions because for the Stoics
preconceptions are prolate since these
general principles they play an
incredibly important role in our
practical reasoning they are essentially
cognitive in the way that we look at
them but then we also have desires and
aversions you know we come to situations
already sort of being effectively
steered in this direction and away from
this thing over here you know some of
these things that are rather trivial do
you you know do you like broccoli or not
do you like Brussels sprouts or not I
was not a picky eater as a kid but I've
seen plenty of kids who were picky
eaters including my sibling and you know
those are divided desires and aversions
we could have much more important
desires and aversions they have to bear
on things that have got a quick Momentis
for us right he had those desires and
aversions they have a aspect of sidon
else
cognitive side they are involved in
judgments about what is good and what is
bad
they could be conclusions of processes
of practical reasoning emotions emotions
for the Stoics are not just feelings
that come over us they involve some sort
of value judgments and quite often some
sort of inferential process than we have
taken that arrives at feeling and
emotion as a conclusion so when we feel
a sense of you know great joy
you know elation beyond you know what's
what's what's strictly speaking within
the range or the limits of reason which
the stoical say whether you be a little
bit careful about that that is something
that can not only lead to people seeing
things in a certain way or choosing a
certain way it can also be the product
of that habits habits are generated by
doing similar things over and over and
over again we have good habits we have
bad habits those play an incredibly
important role as far as epictetus is
concerned in the way that we use our
rational Faculty of the Faculty of
choice in the way that we draw
conclusions habits sometimes almost you
know substitute for or guide of
automatically the processes of reasoning
so if I'm an angry person by the habit
of interpreting people talking about
things as insults to myself that then I
have to avenge the anger itself is an
emotion but the habit does a lot of the
thinking for me and then am I sort of
assent to and I go along with that and I
wound up in a certain conclusion what
epictetus calls appearance is the font
hacia though literally the things that
appear to us the things that we
experience how we how we view them that
is also a major part of our SAR the raw
material for our practical reasoning all
of these things go into the
hopper that we could say or you know the
machine or the grinder of the rational
faculty and the Faculty of choice which
comes to some sort of conclusion and I
put this error of here showing that the
process is a continual one there's
there's something like a feedback loop
particularly with habits but also with
beliefs and desires and aversions right
so what ends up being the conclusion and
one movement can then come in and become
a belief or be an aversion or be an
emotion that is you know functioning and
wrong material for the decision-making
process or the thinking things out
process that will lead to another
conclusion I also put a sort of arrow
here representing the fact that for
Epictetus and we're going to talk about
this in just a moment the rational
faculty or the Faculty of choice is
reflexive we do have some degree of
freedom and responsibility for how we
use our intellect or how we think about
things how we reason things out in
practical matters we are not mere a lot
Samet ons although we can often reason
in ways that that seem kind of like that
but we have some measure capacity to
change the ways that we think about
things the judgments that we've arrived
it even the effective things like
emotions desires and aversions we have
some degree of control over that as well
so let's go through this this material
now it's very important to point out
that for the Stoics much of our
practical reasoning is not carried out
in an explicit way as a matter of fact
some of the exercises that we would want
to do if we were trying to use stomach
philosophy in a practical way would be
taking implicit processes of reasoning
and making them explicit so
we can actually get a good look at them
and then decided whether they make sense
or not or whether we want to keep them
or modify them that by the way is also
another thing that cognitive behavior
therapy which is connected with the
stoicism also does so when we say that
something is explicit we mean that we
you know we're actually engaging in it
in a way where it's visible we might be
doing a pro and con list we might be
using some sort of decision-making
procedure we might be talking it out
with somebody else implicit processes
means that there is a reasoning process
going on but it's kind of below the
surface or at least parts of it are
below the surface when we talk about
making assumptions that's that's
implicit right there so there's a lot
that ends up being implicit I don't
think that Epictetus actually thinks
that we should try to make everything
that's the implicit explicit but there
will be some some involvement in that
now he's also got this wonderful image
that he uses in this chapter and also in
other areas of currency being trade and
this might give you the sense that much
of our reasoning our practical reasoning
about you know things that we value is
in some sense automatic and it can go
automatically it has to go automatically
much of the time but that doesn't mean
that it does so all the time so here's
here's a how he he frames this metaphor
he says it's the nature of every soul to
assent to the true distance from the
false under withhold judgment in a
matter of uncertainty so is it is its
nature to be moved with desire towards
the good and with aversion towards the
evil and to feel neutral towards what we
call the other good nor evil so a lot of
this depends on whether we're getting
good and evil correct right so if we
think that something is good we feel a
desire right if I think eating candy all
day is good I'm going to desire to
eating candy all day so he says just as
neither the banker nor the green grocer
may legally refuse the
coinage of Caesar but if you present it
whether he likes it or not
he has to turn over to you what you are
purchasing with it also it is with the
soul the instant the good appears it
attracts the soul to itself while the
evil repels the soul from itself sort of
like this you know currency giving you
give the the grocer the coin he's got to
give you the lettuce and you can't say
sorry refusing service or anything like
that and apathy this is a view so he
says the soul will never refuse a
clearer sense impression of good any
more than a man will refuse the coinage
of Caesar on this concept of the good
hangs every impulse to act both of man
and of God so he goes up a little bit
further and he says when therefore
different persons have different pieces
of coinage a man who offers the coin
gets with his blog but no what does he
what is he talking about there well
different people are working with
different conceptions that they have
about what is fundamentally good and
what is fundamentally bad for them what
it is that they desire in our verse - so
he says a thief has come to the province
as proconsul what coinage does he use
silver offer it and carry away what you
wish you can bribe it right because he
is going to come to conclusions like oh
well that guy is bribing me that's a
good thing for me I'll take the bride
and let him you know take the
amphitheater or whatever right I'll let
him get off of the the trial even though
I should convict him that's a practical
reasoning conclusion right there an
adulterer has come what coinage does he
use frail wenches takes as one the coin
and sell me the little baggage give and
buy another is interested in boys give
him the coin and take what you wish
another is fond of hunting give him a
fine horse or dog with sighs and groans
he will sell for it what you wish for
another constraints and from within the
one who has established this
and who has established that currency
the person is establishing that currency
for themselves so what does this mean it
means that it's quite important for you
to figure out what your currency is or
as we often say what is the price by
which you might be bought and I've got
another core concept video specifically
about thinking about the prices of
things in this metaphor that epictetus
has so I don't need to go into great
detail about that but the point here is
that it works almost like an economic
transaction there is a kind of automatic
flow to our practical reasoning
processes unless of course we intervene
if we reflect upon them which is
something that is within our power if we
engage in reflective determination of
practical reasoning processes like what
we do when we decide to say what is
going on with me how the hell did I
arrive at that conclusion that was a
good thing for me to do we take an
implicit process would make it explicit
we see the places where perhaps you know
we should reject this appearance or we
should say well that emotion isn't
really relevant here or you know we look
at a desire and it seems to be for a
good thing but then we look at it closer
we say that's not really a good thing
I'm not happy that I'm feeling that
desire
I'd better suspend that for a moment or
we look at our beliefs do we have good
grounds for the things that we are
believing or assuming about people were
capable of reflectively intervening with
our own processes of practical reason
becoming conscious of them and then
tinkering around with them to improve
them now when we look at our processes
of practical reasoning we will probably
see that we have all sorts of
contradictions that don't appear when we
only look at the single you know process
you know starting with some some
premises and carrying out an inference
and arriving at some sort of practical
conclusion it's when we start placing
these
conclusions in relation to each other or
when we start looking very carefully at
the raw material that we're beginning
with or we start looking at how we carry
out this process of inference we may
start to notice what Epictetus calls
literally conflicts mocking it's worth
use for battle but we translated as
contradictions and you can think of it
as a practical contradiction within the
person so if the person says something
like you often see people doing I think
that having self-control is a really
great thing and I value that within my
life and then you watch them and they're
over at the buffet stuffing themselves
with you know their fifth plate of food
and they're coming over to the table in
there you can't believe I ate so much
there's some sort of contradiction going
up things are not lining up and there is
a process of practical reasoning that
happened in probably an implicit one you
know something like this man food is
really great it tastes great and it's so
wonderful to eat lots and lots of food
there's food over there I should go over
there and eat as much as I possibly can
there's the conclusion right then the
guy stops himself all that well he has
arrived at that through a process of
reasoning and the way that you're going
to get him to stop doing that is to get
him to see that reasoning process and
we're the flaws in it are where are the
conflicts with the other things that he
claims to value are and then he'll have
to make a decision because it's his
Faculty of choice or his rational
faculty about what he wants to give
priority to this is why from a stoic
perspective you can't actually make
other people good that's not something
within your your realm of action of the
things that are your business that's up
to them they they are an independent
person with their own Faculty of choice
they have to decide whether they
to become more practical irrational or
not
now the same thing applies to us we can
scrutinize ourselves and we have to
decide we want to improve our processes
of practical reasoning or not part of
that means admitting where our processes
are going wrong